So, after having looped through, after having iterated through
the entire data set, millions and millions of tags,
okay? Then what I'm going to do is print out
the data that I found from my audit. Okay,
so it actually takes a little while for that
to run. So I've run it already, okay? And
here's what the output looks like, okay? So, there
actually aren't that many unusual values. What I find is,
so in the United States, and this is going to vary from
one country to another. In the United States, we number certain
types of roads. So, this would be a U.S. Highway, United
States Highway. Same thing with 53, 59 and so on, alright? So,
that's why I'm seeing these as keys. Alright? Now, this is
odd. My guess is, these look like zip codes to me, or
postal codes. Alright? Another. Road number, okay? And then I'm seeing
different forms of, of avenue, right? . And as I move through
this, okay, so here's a good example of a
set for this particular key value here, for court, okay?
So these are all of the different uses of CT
as an abbreviation for court in this particular data set.
Okay, and as I scroll through this, I see the
rest of the unusual street types. Okay? Now what I
have to decide, and basically this is the process that
you're going to to follow through the, the next few exercises
is, which of these are okay, and which of
them do I need to do something about? South avenue
L? That's actually a correct way of representing a
street name, there's nothing wrong with that. It's just that
it wasn't expected in my audit. It's okay though,
I would probably not want to do anything to change how
this is represented. On the other hand, I don't
really like all caps, abbreviations, so I would probably transform
all of the abbreviations into the specific word that that represents. So for
example, PKWY is an abbreviation for Parkway, okay? So, that's what I would
probably use there, alright? And the same with other abbreviations that we find
here. Street, terrace, so on. Okay, so your general process for the exercises
that follow is going to be to write some
code to audit the data, and then decide what type
of fixes you want to apply to that data.
And then write the code that actually performs the fix.
What you're going to be doing is building up a
code base that will allow you to add data to
MongoDB in such a way that you're cleaning it. So
with each step, you're going to have increasingly clean data.
So one way of going about this would be to do all
of your auditing and all of your cleaning up front, and then
put all of the data into MongoDB, okay? And that would be
a perfectly reasonable way to go about doing it. You can also
take a more iterative approach to it, and clean one piece of
data at a time, or one type of data at a time,
and then, sort of reload your data in MongoDB. Now, the data
set that you'll have will be small enough, that will be possible, okay?
It's really up to you how you want to
approach this problem. So again, our basic process here,
or as we called it in lesson three, our
blueprint, is going to be to audit a particular type
of data, develop a plan for cleaning, write code
to clean and go again, okay? With the next
type of data that we want to then audit
and develop a plan and eventually code for cleaning. Okay.
When you're all done, you will have gone through a process of
cleaning up various facets of the data so that it's ready to be
stored in our database. You'll also have gained quite a bit of experience
with parsing XML using event-based parsing.
Good luck with the next several exercises.